Do you have any experience of caregiving?
I've never done it, but I'm sure I could learn.
Then let's go and meet Will.
Will, this is Louisa Clark.
Nathan will talk you through Will's routines and equipment.
You don't have to talk across me, mother.
My brain isn't paralyzed... yet.
Good morning.
He hates me.
Every time I speak, he looks at me like I'm stupid.
To be fair, you are pretty stupid.
Yeah, but he doesn't know that yet.
No, stay.
Tell me something good.
When I was little, my favorite outfit was my bumblebee tights.
Bumblebee tights.
Black and yellow stripes.
Oh, dear God.
Didn't you ever love anything that much?
Yes.
I don't want you to miss all the things that someone else could give you.
But I can make you happy.
I have become a whole new person because of you.
Do you know something, Clark?
You are pretty much the only thing that makes me want to get up in the morning.